nous passons à un sujet plus
international vous savez qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un sommet pour le climat
organisée par les nations unies de très
nombreux chefs d'état et de gouvernement
vont intervenir avec deux exceptions
notables
le patron d'ubs aux pressions du brésil
et le président trump qui lui s'est
retiré du jeu sur ce sujet le climat y a
rien de plus important
et si vous l'aviez oublié jean yves le
drian qui est à new york depuis hier le
rappel le climat est la priorité absolue
de notre action et celle du déplacement
du président de la république à new york
la situation est grave
les voyants sont au rouge qu'on nous le
dise
les derniers rapports du giec à la fois
sur les seules et sur les océans est le
propre de l'actualité c'est qu'elle
évolue tout le temps est comme ça mais
en direct je vous donne cette épaisse
donald trump fait une apparition
surprise au sommet climat de l'onu
donc ce que je vous ai dit à 45 le
président américain y est allés est-ce
qu'il va s'exprimer ça pour l'instant je
ne le sais pas avant de lancer le débat
pour savoir si ce sommet est d'abord une
affaire de communication
je vous propose d'écouter yannick jadot
c'était le patron et de la liste europe
écologie les verts aux dernières
européennes
et voici sa démonstration qui est une
sorte déclinaison du du pardon de la
phrase bien connue grands diseux petit
faiseux main depuis des années des
années de grands discours de grands
slogans et on est souvent fiers que nos
présidents de la république porte la
voix de la france et du climat dans
l'est dans les enceintes atteint soeur
souvenez-vous jacques chirac la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs
le seul problème c'est qu'on n'agit pas
les grands discours n'ont jamais
économisé une seule tonne de co2 et nous
allions agnès verdier-molinié la
directrice de la fondation ifrap qui
nous a rejoint bonjour amis soyez la
bienvenue
ivan rioufol est ce que c'est un coup de
communication seulement est-ce que le le
constat de yannick jadot est juste on
parle trop on n'agit pas assez
constatons qu'il y a deux ans on ne
parlait pas de
ce climat de ces catastrophes
climatiques
en tout cas le gouvernement n'en parlez
pas le président de la république n'en
parlait pas il en parle aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya eu une reconversion
électorale peut-être une reconversion
effectivement dans ses convictions
moi je les crois effectivement déçu je
crois que ses convictions sont tout à
fait perméable à l'air du temps donc je
vois beaucoup de communication et je
vois surtout de sa part une manière
puisque l'on voit que les grands sujets
mondiaux mondialistes échappe maintenant
à l'intérêt des les foules qui vont au
contraire se se préserve de la
mondialisation pour retrouver les
sentiments de souveraineté jlm je trouve
que là de défendre la planète le climat
est une autre manière à une sorte de
faux nez pour défendre cette
globalisation qui est rejeté par par les
peuples les peuples les plus vulnérables
en tout cas et donc j'y vois une
manoeuvre comme de communication et une
manoeuvre politique je ne vois pas
beaucoup effectivement de deux passions
de passion intérieur on peut dire didier
pourquoi et qu'on est plutôt des bons
élèves nous les français on aimait
plutôt moins de gaz à effet de serre que
les autres notamment grâce au nucléaire
la théologie pas assez tout à fait oui
une chaque fois on met en avant ce genre
de choses pour répondre à votre question
ça fait 30 ans qu'on le discute à l'onu
de problèmes de climat et c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait dire que si c'est pas
passé grand chose mais on peut voir
aussi le verre à moitié plein et se dire
que il ya eu quand même des avancées la
coop 21 il y avait un certain nombre il
y avait un certain nombre de d'objets
ctif et là on va le on va le juger sur
deux choses si c'est si c'est justement
grâce un coup de com ou pas c est ce que
on va butter reste le secrétaire général
de l'onu dit qu'il faut qu'il faut avoir
de une baisse de 45%
comme objectif des gaz à effet de serre
d'ici 2030 l'europe 10 55 % de baisse
il y à des pays qui sont plus vertueux
que d'autres ce qui serait vraiment bien
ça serait que emmanuel macron par
exemple disent on va faire 65%
on se fixe 65% comme objectif d'ici 2030
ça serait bien c'est le premier point
sur lequel ben on saura dans d'ici
quelques d'ici quelques heures
et le deuxième point c'est quand même si
sur la finance un jour et quand même
juste souligner ça il ya le fond vert il
ya et la finance verte qui doit qui doit
mettre en place quelque chose pour aider
les pays du sud à se mettre au niveau
des pays enfin approcher les niveaux des
pays du nord
hélas pour le moment on avait parlé de
10 milliards on en est à 8 milliards de
fonds vert il se passe pas grand chose
là aussi c'est là dessus qu'on va qu'on
va juger s'il se passe quelque chose ou
pas puisque ces pays sont plutôt moins
vertueux que variés occident exactement
en matière de pollution
agnès verdier-molinié je vous imagine
tiraillé entre la fibre écologiste que
vous avez comme nous tous qui sommes
soucieux de l'avenir de la planète
et puis se dire qu'en général quand on
veut agir pour le climat on augmente les
impôts ou les taxes sur les carburants
exactement ça la question c'est d'abord
c'est est ce que la france est vraiment
si polluantes ou est-ce qu'elle a des
émissions qui sont supérieurs aux autres
pays on est à 1 %
donc c'est bien inférieur en émanations
de co2 donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que par rapport à notre pub par
rapport au pic mondial on est inférieur
donc on a fait le boulot et puis par
rapport à ce que disait yannick jadot
tout à l'heure il dit rien n'a été fait
mais c'est pas vrai en réalité en
pourcentage on était à 1,6 en 2002 quand
justement quand jacques chirac disait
faut autour de la maison brûle et c est
maintenant on est 1 % donc on a quand
même réduit et d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron a dit ce qui
ils manifestent pour le climat ce
week-end à paris devrait aller
manifester dans les pays où on fait
moins attention justement bologne
oui mais même ils devraient aller en
chine parce que là c'est 28 % des
émissions de co2 c'est pas c'est pas en
pensant en colonne ses rangs pour cent
donc il faut se poser vraiment la
question à chaque fois 2 est ce qu'on
n'est pas est-ce qu'on va pas trop loin
parce que nous en france pendant que
d'autres récupérer nos industries on
s'est énormément d industrialiser on a
beaucoup taxer un et les taxes nature on
va publier bientôt la fondation ifrap
l'évolution sur les ménages et sur les
entreprises de la fiscalité écologique
et ces dernières années ça a pris 12
milliards de plus donc ce qui était
prévu qui a été supprimée par et gilet
jaune c'était encore plus que çà et là
ont le meilleur le conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires la semaine
dernière a rendu un rapport super
intéressant ils disent que c'est 56
milliards de fiscalité que paie les
français ménages et entreprises tous les
ans en fiscalité écologique
donc si on regarde où l'avait dit
monsieur il y a des des objectifs de la
france qui sont supérieures d'ailleurs
aux objectifs internationaux
c'est la loi climat énergie dans cette
loi climat énergie on veut atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 on veut
réduire la consommation énergétique des
énergies fossiles de 40 % en 2030 et on
veut réduire la part du nucléaire
paradoxe ultime parce que c'est ça qui
nous permet d'avoir des émissions de co2
qu'ils soient inférieurs et vous vous
dites c'est pas la peine de faire ça
puisque déjà on dit mais pourquoi alors
qu'on a déjà une industrie qui est dans
une situation critique qu'elle
représente que 12% du pib alors que les
allemands sont à 20%
pourquoi est-ce que quoi quand on voit
notre balance commerciale et que
finalement c'est en chine que se
produisent les produits qu'ensuite nous
importons est d'ailleurs le conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires le dit un
paradoxe total c'est qu'en même temps on
produit moins en france on pollue moins
mais on va acheter des produits dans des
pays qui polluent plus est ce que c'est
ça la logique donc il ya vraiment une
vision globale à avoir d'abord s se
poser la question est ce que c'est en
france qu'on va créer nos emplois verts
parce que tout le monde a envie d angle
d'avoir des emplois verts mais si on met
des contraintes tellement énorme qu'à la
fin les emplois il se crée en dehors de
nos frontières
ce sera pas bon pour nos enfants nos
petits-enfants pour la croissance
française et pour finalement de notre
création de richesses à tous merci
maximum
vous convaincu par ce plaidoyer pas
forcément surtout que j'entendais des
choses et c'est certainement de ma faute
mais que je trouverai un peu coup je
trouve un peu contradictoire d'abord sur
ce que vous évoquiez c'est à dire le
fait qu'on ait notre part relative parce
que c'est une part relative qui soit en
diminution c'est aussi le fait
évidemment de l'augmentation relative
des autres pays de cons est passé de 1 6
1 % des émissions de co2 si je vous
rappelle que entre temps la chine vous
l'avez d'ailleurs souligné lui à
augmenter ne serait ce que parce qu'elle
a une activité économique un peu plus
importante mais passons ce que moi je
retiens de ce sommet et pour le coup
c'est ce que vous indiquez c'est
qu'effectivement il faut qu'ils aient
des réponses globales et on sait bien
qu'on ne va pas faire le socialisme dans
un seul pays mais l'écologisme dans un
seul pays
c'est très juste mais pour pouvoir y
arriver il faut donc qu'on renforce le
multilatéralisme et moi ce que je
retiens de ce sommet vous parler de coup
de com c'est que je crois en tout cas la
volonté
je ne sais pas si elle sera victorieuse
mais du secrétaire général de l'onu de
vouloir imposer un endroit des changes
de discussion voire de diffusion de 10
des décisions pardon qui soit un endroit
qui en l'occurrence et l'onu qu'ils
soient multilatérale et moi je m'en
félicite
donc moi j'attends effectivement ils
puissent avoir des engagements qu'ils
soient des engagements communs après
pour pouvoir convaincre des partenaires
il vaut mieux être exemplaire
est ce que la france l'est vous indiquez
que l'on à des prélèvements obligatoires
qui sont nourris de prélèvement
écologique
moi je regarde aussi la destination ces
prélèvements là et je crois qu'on sera
d'accord vous et moi pourquoi pour
considérer que ces prélèvements
obligatoires qui sont censés financer la
transition écologique ne les finance pas
c'est d'ailleurs un mois de l'état donc
ça c'est une vraie difficulté et enfin
moi je crois que au delà des efforts que
nous devrions
faire d'un point de vue financier pour
pouvoir réussir la transition écologique
cette transition c'est un changement de
modèle et donc c'est aussi une
opportunité
si on veut bien y croire de
transformation de notre économie et à
c'est dans ce cadre là moi je note que
la france et qui n'a pas de stratégie de
véritables de stratégie transition
écologique menée par ce gouvernement
d'un point de vue budgétaire comme en
termes d'appui de filières ça c'est une
évidence aujourd'hui on dit qu'il faut
faire du bio mais la réalité c'est qu'on
n'est pas les agriculteurs à pouvoir
transformer leurs modèles or ils ont
besoin d'être aidés pour pouvoir y
arriver et que parallèlement à ça il ya
deux pays qui font plus en l'occurrence
j'ai noté moins ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement allemand
généralement il m'a même un coin bien
citer les allemands en modèle je
constate juste que ils sont capables
d'annoncer un plan de 1000 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2030 sur la question de
la transition écologique quand nous nous
faisons 10 fois moins mais il a donc ils
partent de plus loin des usines à
charbon pendant que nous on est on est
sur des centrales nucléaires qui
polluent beaucoup moins et pendant ce
temps là aussi on a une par exemple la
plasturgie
on a des usines en france qui
aujourd'hui se pose la question parce
qu'ils sont en train de produire des
couverts en plastique qui vont bientôt
être interdite donc ils savent pas
exactement ce qui va se passer pour eux
et pendant ce temps là on va importer
des couverts en plastique qui sont
produits dans des pays limitrophes en
europe sas a aucun sens alors ça n'a
aucun sens mais regardez quand on pose
la question aujourd'hui des accords de
libre échange et qu'on pose la question
de l'empreinte écologique comme étant
une condition ça a du sens deuxièmement
quand vous posez la question du
nucléaire
sauf que derrière it was on viserait les
usines qui ferment c'est horrible le
nucléaire c'est bien la porte du
nucléaire aujourd'hui y compris dans
l'empreinte écologique national
mais il faut aussi avoir en tête que
aujourd'hui les investissements en
matière d'énergie en termes de recherche
95% des investissements en france vont
dans la filière nucléaire
donc de toutes façons ne sera pas
capable de trouver des solutions
intermédiaires comme l'a fait le
portugal qui aujourd'hui est à 100%
donner à 110 % d'énergies renouvelables
parce que ils ont eu un plan avec des
investissements financiers mais qui sont
des investissements d'avenir
ils ont une véritable stratégie
concertée nous nous faisons pas donc
c'est normal mais résiste bien on va
importer des matrices produite en chine
qui sont moins chers que chez nous et
alors que l'immigré cela pourrait être
développé pour stocker de l'énergie
nous on va pas le faire donc je vous
pour la donner à nos internautes qui
sont plutôt d'accord avec vous en tout
cas si ge qui dit on pourrait laisser
nos entreprises bosser sans se faire
massacrer de taxes et de normes il faut
commencer par favoriser la production
locale et il ajouté c'est un débat
passionnant si l'écologie était au coeur
du mandat de macron il ne signerait pas
de traité de libre échange
je vous donnerai c'est de votre vote
puisque on vous invite à donner votre
point de vue vous qui êtes en train de
nous suivre
grâce à twitter le sommet du climat est
il uniquement un coup de com à vous êtes
76 % à considérer que oui
brownie tôt nous dit la jeune greta
allusion à la jeune crétin tomberg bien
sûr là la suédoise qui s'est exprimé au
sommet de l'onu
c'est un produit de qom par excellence
selon lui où selon elle car je ne sais
pas si brawn ito est un monsieur au
wyndham et babineau nous dit il ya
toujours un décalage entre les belles
paroles et le manque d'action du
gouvernement contre le réchauffement